Miller chips the puck into the devil Zone
Sean PA around for heer and here comes Devils
two onone Bratt with poot J for brat sces F
the pass across and put it past Demco J for
brat at 340 of the first makes it one- nothing
for the Devils three man Advantage breaks odd
Rush breaks this Puck is going to bounce past
Heron and it's the two-on-one brat is looking
for pilot but Quinn Hughes takes that pass away
he allows brat to square up and shoot this and
he beats Demco through the feet good release
Here by esper Brad is ninth of the season and
so Michael mlau trying to defend without a stick
here his team already short handed Hughes has the
punt Pon takes his pass relays
to Brock besser down the cloud
hustles to the bench to get a stick conck
looking take advantage centering pass get
his it was a five on three just for a moment
and the Canucks strike to tie the game in
one heads to the bench right there to go
get a stick as he gets it now that opens
up that pass quick back Pon to besser I
talked earlier about the rebounds that
will be there vanich leaves Loose Change in
the cre Miller's right on top of the cree
Marino GT came into the day tied for second
in NHL scoring with 36 points teita COV was
leading away 42 here's a long lead pass
Jack Hughes greeted by Myers in the now
H seters all ERS Holly stores Canucks lost
track of Eric holl Hugh it and it's two on
Devils New Jersey and he's going to be all alone
in front of the net as you see both Meyers and
zadorov end up in the corner but Miller's there
too with the third player nobody reacted to the
puck being controlled by Jack Hughes in the
corner que Hughes hson killer on the goal line
and now now it's off Escape M Miller able to
get to the buck keep alive kle from the side
Pon stop rebound M couldn't put it home Pon kco
blocked by Heir kzco makes this terrific pass to
Pon there's the rebound that comes right to Brock
besser and with vanich on his stomach in a snow
angel a reverse snow angel besser just shoots
it right off his Pad he doesn't see it Miller
ends up saving that thing as it's rolling back
in the crease and so one Center waved out Luger
for the Canucks has been warned now they drop
the punck and here's a chance in front tucked
in by Jack Hughes Kevin Ball just threw it on goal
and Hughes was able to kick it up and tuck it home
and it's 3-1 Devils out of the faceoff Circle
Jack Hughes beats bler on the draw and bler
slow getting back to the net bler got a shield
Jack Hughes from going to the net and he's all
by himself and he pushes it onto his backand
and coming coming in into the game leading the
NHL Brock besser battling for the punk deep in
his own Zone balls down from the Blue Line puts
one in front and a good job by besser to tie
up Nathan Bastion now a shot from Marino goes
wide H thrown in front that defle it
and they J it home another goal for New
Jersey Michael McLoud was able to pop
that loose one into the net and it's 4-1
besser and Bastion are at the front of
the crease and when ronic gets there too
there's all kinds of traffic in front of Demco
this puck gets deflected so Demco doesn't get
a solid square up save to it Lazar shot is
deflected by Bastion and McLoud gets here's
Tyler Myers to Nikita sedoro takes the puck
wide on Colin sends it in front Teddy bler
sets up shop on the near side puts one in
front tipped on go by Garland rebound sh
scores Dakota Joshua standing
his ground in front able to
Coral that Puck and slide it in to make it four to
two really strong Rush by zidor off to get into
the zone and Bluer going to reset
the deflection by Garland allows
and the Devils win it Luke Hughes to Jack Hughes
R shot s for the sand now Luke Hugh scores Puck
bounced out to him and he just ripped it past
Demco Luke Hughes on the board and it's five
to2 on a power play goal a broken play and the
puck bounces up in the air Luke Hugh is going to
find it first I guess Jack hes passing it back it
gets deflected by bler on the way back and this is
clean quickly delivered wrist
shot perfectly placed for Luke
Hughes can start with the pocket
Center Cole sends it below the
goal line hoglander into pressure of the
pcket Miller gets it centers it B scores
his League leading 18th of the year which matches
his total from last season started 15 seconds
earlier with Miller's hit out at center right
polander in on the for check contact turns the
puck over and Sean ball is pinned behind the net
a really shaky start he's hung in there he made a
good save in there he had to fight to make that
safe here's Pon back to Hughes quen Hughes rot
I think ly might have got it in
front CS within a goal with 602 to
play and they take advantage of a break is
guer brat has the puck he loses it here's
Miller again leaves for Quinn Hughes
Meyers on him Hughes nice move of the
line tried to shot that was blocked gets it
again Hughes puts it on goal rebound Homer
scores Neils homelander having himself a period
and he is rewarding with a goal that ties the
game in five Quinn Hughes is an escape artist
he's at the blue line there's nowhere to go
man team o Myers's got to be a lot harder
on the play than that Quinn Hughes blows
him off the play there Myro weighs him
by about 40 pounds and as Quinn Hughes
keeps this thing rolling the save off the
rebound shorty we talked about it 5 minutes
into the game when you play VC vanich there's
always rebounds thank you very much for Neil
hoglander an unbelievable night from the
fourth line to the first line fends off
a check and dumps the puck back in Ian Cole
up the boards holding it in at the point is
ball across the Marino rist walk down here's
poot turning feeds back ball wrist shot stop
scores Jasper brat open the scoring
has he closed it as well it's 6 five
Devils the play continues on in D to
D pass and you'll see brat come around
the back of the net the Canucks don't
identify him in time and as brat goes
all the way around again a deflected shot
in front of the net it doesn't allow the
goenda Dem CO's pad down for Pon should to
hit his glow not sure that one loved by lery
play goes on M with a shot and blocker saved by
manich and that'll do it vanich one last stop